It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这可真是一个不会错过的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. As we gather around Thanksgiving tables with our friends and family, many of us may take a moment to think about the things we're grateful for in our lives. For parents, the season may be a reminder that gratitude is something they want to cultivate in their kids year-round. After all, studies have shown that a grateful attitude can help us cope with challenges, and gratitude is good for our relationships, our mental health, and even our physical health. But figuring out how to foster gratitude in kids isn't always easy or obvious. How do we raise children who don't just say thank you, but feel thankful, kids who recognize generosity and think about others? At what age can kids start to understand gratitude and how does
在网络高流量期间，Google Fi Wireless 不会遭遇数据流量降速。当我们与亲朋好友围坐在感恩节的餐桌旁时，我们许多人可能会花一点时间思考生活中让我们感恩的事物。对于父母来说，这个季节可能会提醒他们，感恩是他们希望全年都在孩子身上培养的一种品质。毕竟，研究表明，感恩的态度可以帮助我们应对挑战，而且感恩对我们的关系、心理健康甚至身体健康都有好处。但是，弄清楚如何在孩子心中培养感恩并不总是那么容易或显眼。我们如何抚养那些不仅会说谢谢，而且心怀感恩、能够识别慷慨并为他人着想的孩子？孩子们从什么年龄开始理解感恩，以及
their understanding change over time? How can you teach your children to appreciate what they have while acknowledging frustration, unfairness, and disappointment? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology. the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Andrea Hussong, a professor of psychology and neuroscience at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill.
他们的理解如何随时间而改变？你如何教导你的孩子欣赏他们所拥有的东西，同时承认挫折、不公和失望？欢迎收听《心理学聊天室》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校（University of North Carolina Chapel Hill）心理学和神经科学教授安德里亚·胡松（Andrea Hussong）博士。
Dr. Hussong is a developmental scientist and a licensed clinical psychologist whose work focuses on promoting health and well-being in children, youth, and families. She's studied how children learn gratitude and has developed a program called Raising Grateful Children to Help Families Put the Science of Gratitude into practice. Dr. Hussung, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. I'm delighted to be here. Let's start with a definition of the term. What does gratitude mean to you and how do you define it in your research? Well, that turns out to be a more challenging question than we might think.
胡松博士是一位发展科学家兼执业临床心理学家，其工作重点是促进儿童、青少年和家庭的健康与福祉。她研究过儿童如何学习感恩，并开发了一个名为“培养感恩儿童”（Raising Grateful Children）的项目，旨在帮助家庭将感恩科学付诸实践。胡松博士，非常感谢您今天能来。非常感谢邀请我。我很高兴能来到这里。让我们从这个词的定义开始。对您来说，感恩意味着什么？您在研究中又是如何定义它的？嗯，事实证明，这是一个比我们想象的更具挑战性的问题。
There's a lot of different ways that people talk about gratitude. And a lot of the gratitude that I'm focused on really began with asking parents how they actually were defining gratitude. And when we did that, we found that parents really focused a lot on interpersonal gratitude or the gratitude we have for one another. And they focused not so much on having grateful children as having kids who have grateful moments. So instead of thinking about it like personality or disposition, more thinking about it, how do you cultivate those moments in your kids. So we ended up working with parents to try to figure out that definition. And we talk about it in terms of having four beats in a moment, what kids notice to be grateful for, and then how do they make
人们谈论感恩的方式有很多种。我所关注的很多感恩，实际上始于询问父母他们是如何真正定义感恩的。当我们这样做时，我们发现父母非常关注人际感恩，也就是我们对彼此的感恩。他们关心的与其说是拥有一个感恩的孩子，不如说是拥有懂感恩时刻的孩子。因此，与其把它看作是一种性格或倾向，不如想想如何在你的孩子身上培养这些时刻。因此，我们最终与父母合作，试图找出这个定义。我们从一个时刻的四个节拍来讨论它：孩子们注意到什么值得感恩，然后他们如何通过自己的思想和感受来理解
sense of what they're noticing through their thoughts and their feelings. And then how do they act on that? What do they do and to show gratitude? So we talk about this notice, think, feel, do model to help parents think about the ways that gratitude comes together in a moment for their kid. And a lot of parents can see a lot of ways to kind of get in there and shape those moments just by how they think about gratitude in that way. Why should parents want to raise grateful children? What benefit does that have for families and for society in general? Well, there's a lot more research on how the benefits of gratitude play out for adults and then we got younger and looked at it for teenagers. And so there's less that we know about kids, but we can look at that long-term trajectory and know something about that.
他们所注意到的事物。接着他们如何付诸行动？他们做了什么来表达感恩？因此，我们讨论“注意到、思考、感受、行动”（notice, think, feel, do）这个模型，以帮助父母思考感恩如何在孩子身上的某一时刻汇聚在一起。许多父母可以看出很多方法，只要通过他们对感恩的这种思考方式，就能介入并塑造这些时刻。为什么父母想要培养懂感恩的孩子？这对家庭和社会总体有什么好处？嗯，关于感恩对成年人的好处的研究要多得多，后来我们把年龄层降低，研究了青少年。因此，我们对儿童的了解较少，但我们可以通过长期的发展轨迹来了解一些情况。
A lot of the gratitude that we see in kids we think comes out of empathy. So we know that's another way of thinking about how we connect to others. And it's a strong predictor of pro-sociality in kids. So the extent to which kids are really concerned about the welfare of others in their lives. But those benefits then also translate into the social skills kids are developing. As early as six, we're seeing some of that in our work, that we can see some of those more grateful acts of kids. are predicting stronger social skills.
我们认为，在儿童身上看到的很多感恩都源于同理心。所以我们知道，这是我们与他人建立联系的另一种思考方式。它是儿童亲社会性的强烈预测指标。也就是说，儿童对生活中他人福祉的关切程度。但这些益处随后也会转化为儿童正在发展的社交技能。我们在工作中发现，早在六岁时，我们就能看到其中的一些表现，我们可以看到儿童的一些更具感恩的 actúa，不，是感恩的行为。在预测更强的社交技能。
And as they get older, we see effects on well-being, less depression, and being able to have those kind of social connections, which is what we think about gratitude being important for. How can we identify people in our world who they like us? They have a positive bond to us. And then we know who to count on as we're looking for people in our lives that can support us. That's fairly simple to teach very young children the words, please, and thank you. But at what age do kids really start to understand gratitude or to feel gratitude?
随着他们年龄的增长，我们看到它对幸福感的影响、减少抑郁，并且能够建立那种社交联系，这就是我们认为感恩很重要的原因。我们如何识别我们世界中那些喜欢我们的人？他们对我们有积极的纽带。然后，当我们寻找生活中能够支持我们的人时，我们就知道可以依靠谁。教导幼儿说“请”和“谢谢”这些词相当简单。但是，孩子们在什么年龄才真正开始理解感恩或感受到感恩？
And how does this understanding change as they get older? Yeah, that is exactly where we started in this work. And I always think of a six-year-old that we had in one of our early focus groups. And she just looked at this and she said, you know, he said thank you, but he didn't mean it. And at six, she already got it. She already got the idea that saying thank you and being grateful is not the same thing. So it's going to vary like anything from kid to kid. And it's not one of those I wake up in the morning and I'm all the sudden getting it.
这种理解随着年龄的增长又是如何变化的？是的，这正是我们这项工作的起点。我总是想起我们早期某个焦点小组里的一个六岁女孩。她看着这个，然后说，你知道，他说谢谢，但他不是真心实意的。在六岁的时候，她就已经明白了。她已经明白了说谢谢和心怀感恩并不是一回事。所以，就像任何事情一样，这会因孩子而不同。而且这不是那种我早上醒来，突然就懂了的事情。
But we think a lot of the development of gratitude builds off this early empathy. And so that's sort of the early building blocks that we see for gratitude. And then kids come into line with how much they notice and how much they engage in behaviors or what they do to show appreciation. but all that making meaning of what you have through your thoughts and feelings seems to take a little bit longer to come online and gets more sophisticated. So kids will be more grateful for really concrete things when they're younger, a gift they've been given or a special dinner that they receive. And it may take a little bit older until they're getting up to 10, 11, 12, until they get into less concrete things to be thankful for. A girl in one of our studies, I think she was probably around eight or nine, was drawing a picture of what she was grateful for and it was a horse. And we thought, oh, she loves horses.
但我们认为，感恩的大部分发展都是建立在早期同理心之上的。因此，这是我们看到的感恩的早期基石。然后，孩子们开始将他们的注意力和参与的行为或他们为表达感激所做的事情保持一致。但是，通过你的思想和感受来理解你所拥有的东西，似乎需要更长的时间才能形成，并且变得更加复杂。因此，年龄较小的孩子会对非常具体的事情更加感恩，比如他们得到的礼物或他们收到的一顿特别的晚餐。可能要大一点，直到他们长到 10 岁、11 岁、12 岁，他们才会开始对不太具体的事情心存感激。我们研究中的一个女孩，我想她大概八九岁吧，当时正在画一幅画，画的是她感激的事物，结果是一匹马。我们想，哦，她喜欢马。
And she told story about how her grandparents would take her to visit this horse and how special it was to be with her grandparents. And it became clear it wasn't the horse. It was this other thing that she had in this relationship. And that's kind of moving from something concrete, something a little bit more abstract to be grateful for. So eight is an age where kids can really understand the depth of what gratitude is. It's not just words. Well, I think that probably is, again, varies from kid to kid. But the more that you've got that perspective taking and the more that you're able to kind of connect the what you're noticing to how you're making meaning of it, that's what we think makes gratitude deeper. More of those connections over time. And yeah, by the time we're entering school, some of that is coming on board and just gets deeper as we get more of that perspective taking. So by 8, 9, 10, we're getting farther.
她讲了一个故事，说她的祖父母带她去探望这匹马，和祖父母在一起是多么特别。很明显，重要的不是这匹马。而是她在这段关系中拥有的另一件东西。这有点像从具体的东西转向更抽象的东西来感恩。所以八岁是一个孩子真正能够理解感恩深度的年龄。它不仅仅是字面上的词语。嗯，我想这可能再次因孩子而不同。但是，你越能进行换位思考，你越能把所注意到的东西与你如何理解它联系起来，我们认为这就是让感恩更深的原因。随着时间的推移，这种联系会更多。是的，到我们入学的时候，其中一些已经开始形成，并且随着我们进行更多的换位思考而变得更深。所以到了 8、9、10 岁，我们走得更远了。
In your work, do you find that most parents say that they want to raise grateful kids? Is this a value that parents have today? Yes. One of the things that surprised me so much about this study is it's a very different area of research for me. I've done a lot of work on sort of addictions and trying to understand. in substance use and a lot of adversity. And this was the first time I tried to recruit parents for a study where we looked at something like gratitude.
在你的工作中，你发现大多数父母都说他们想培养懂感恩的孩子吗？这是当今父母拥有的一种价值观吗？是的。这项研究最让我惊讶的事情之一是，对我来说这是一个非常不同的研究领域。我做过很多关于成瘾以及试图理解物质使用和许多逆境的研究。这是我第一次尝试招募父母参加一项研究，我们研究的是类似感恩的东西。
And the first day I put out a call for parents, we had 70 parents want to be in the study. That just doesn't happen. So we definitely see parents really want to be in the study. And indeed, that's one of the things that's sort of interesting about studying this. People really want to talk to us about it and to engage in this. But the biggest challenge, of course, when we're talking about what parents value for their kids is they value lots of things. And so the challenge is how do you do all those things that you value in a way that's balanced and doesn't drive your family crazy. You've developed a program, as I said in the intro, called Raising Grateful Children that aims to translate your research into practical advice for families.
当我第一天发出招募父母的号召时，就有 70 位父母想要参加这项研究。这在平时是不会发生的。所以我们绝对看到父母真的很想参加这项研究。事实上，这也是研究这个课题有趣的地方之一。人们真的很想和我们谈论这个并参与其中。但最大的挑战当然是，当我们谈论父母为孩子看重的价值时，他们看重很多东西。所以挑战在于，你如何以一种平衡且不会把你的家庭逼疯的方式，来做所有你重视的事情。正如我在引言中所说，你开发了一个名为“培养感恩儿童”的项目，旨在将你的研究转化为给家庭的实用建议。
What are some of the most important pieces of advice you want parents to take from that work? Yeah, we have really focused on what parents are doing here. There's lots of different things out there on the Internet and everywhere in terms of, you know, having a reflective woman at dinner. There's just so many little pieces of things that you can integrate into a day. And rather than focus on those pieces, we're really focused on sort of these habits that parents can get into themselves with the practice of gratitude with their kids. So we focus on four things, really. We focus on parents modeling gratitude. And in that, it's not just what we say because we like this notice think feel-do idea.
你希望父母从这项工作中汲取的最重要的建议有哪些？是的，我们确实专注于父母在这里做什么。互联网上和到处都有很多不同的东西，比如，在晚餐时进行反思。你可以将很多小的事情融入到一天中。与其关注这些碎片，我们真正关注的是父母自己可以养成的、与孩子一起实践感恩的习惯。所以我们实际上关注四件事。我们关注父母为感恩做表率。在这个过程中，不仅仅是我们说什么，因为我们喜欢“注意到、思考、感受、行动”这个理念。
So how do parents model what they're noticing and what they think and feel about what they notice? So helping teach parents to say what they're thinking out loud as they're processing something they're grateful for so kids can see the whole part of the process and not just that thank you at the end. So what they model we think is important, how they select acting. activities for their kids to be in or places to be that might demonstrate gratitude and value gratitude, so they're around that. The third thing is how they talk to their kids about times that they've been grateful, and our intervention really focuses on how to have those conversations in a way that's really productive for kids and focuses on trying to understand why are kids sometimes not grateful, because we focus a lot on not just when kids are grateful in this work, but also in
那么父母如何为他们所注意到的事物以及他们对所注意到的事物的想法和感受树立表率呢？因此，帮助教导父母在处理他们感激的事情时大声说出他们的想法，这样孩子们就能看到整个过程的全部，而不仅仅是最后的那句“谢谢”。所以我们认为他们树立的表率很重要，他们如何选择孩子参与的活动或身处的场所，这些活动或场所可能表现出感恩并重视感恩，这样他们就置身于那种环境中。第三件事是他们如何与孩子谈论他们感恩的时刻，我们的干预真正关注的是如何以对孩子真正有成效的方式进行这些对话，并专注于试图理解为什么有时孩子不感恩，因为我们在工作中不仅关注孩子们什么时候感恩，而且在
and this is what parents get really hot about sometimes when kids miss the opportunity to be grateful. It's right there, they could do it, and they just sort of miss it. And so we like to think about the conversations we have when they hit it right and when they sort of miss it. And then we also talk to parents about the extent to which they are sort of giving these daily reminders and nudges in gratitude moments to kids as they're actually unfolding. So these are sort of habits we help parents think about how they model things, how they give reminders, how they have conversations about those moments, and how they pick things to do that might reinforce gratitude for their kids. What do you think about daily practices like encouraging each family member to say something they're grateful for at the dinner table every night? Is this
有时候，当孩子错过表达感恩的机会时，父母就会非常生气。机会就在那里，他们本可以做到，但他们却错过了。所以我们喜欢思考我们在他们做对了的时候以及他们稍微错过的时候所进行的对话。然后我们还与父母讨论他们在感恩时刻实际展开时给予这些日常提醒和推动的程度。所以这些是我们帮助父母思考的习惯，比如他们如何做表率，他们如何给予提醒，他们如何就这些时刻进行对话，以及他们如何挑选能够为孩子强化感恩的事情。你觉得每天进行一些实践怎么样，比如鼓励每个家庭成员每天晚上在餐桌上说出一件他们感激的事？这
useful or do practices like this become forced or feel insincere? Well, that's a really good question. I think there are a couple of answers, and one of them is really about how the parents' intent are playing out for what they're picking to do with kids in terms of gratitude socialization. So, I mean, some of the work that we have done is found that when parents are really motivated to do things like this, because they want their kids to be mindful and aware. So that example of talking about something at dinner would be, for me, like a notice activity. What do you notice to be grateful for? That tends to increase all the types of gratitude socialization parents do.
有用吗，还是这种做法会变得强迫或显得不真诚？嗯，这是一个非常好的问题。我想有几个答案，其中之一实际上是关于父母的意图如何在他们为与孩子进行感恩社会化而选择做的事情中发挥作用。我的意思是，我们所做的一些研究发现，当父母真的非常有动力去做这样的事情时，是因为他们希望自己的孩子具有正念和意识。所以，在晚餐时谈论某事的那个例子，对流我来说，就像是一个“注意到”的活动。你注意到什么值得感恩？这往往会增加父母所做的所有类型的感恩社会化。
it increases kids' gratitude over time and their pro-social behavior. So we see that as really helpful. But if parents are doing that behavior and their goal is to get their kids to be kind of conforming to social norms, we don't see that they're engaging in other things and we don't see that long-term outcome. So there's got to be some authenticity to it at some level, but both for the parents' intentions as well as for what the kids are doing. When you put out the call for parents to be in your study, what kind of parents said that they wanted to take part? And what did you find out about them? I mean, were they themselves grateful and therefore they were able to model it? Or did you find a lot of parents just didn't quite get it?
它会随着时间的推移增加孩子的感恩和他们的亲社会行为。所以我们认为这真的很有帮助。但如果父母这样做是为了让他们的孩子顺从社会规范，我们就看不到他们在参与其他事情，也看不到那种长期的结果。因此，在某种程度上必须有一定的真实性，这既适用于父母的意图，也适用于孩子所做的事情。当你发出招募父母参加研究的号召时，什么样的父母说他们想参与？你对他们有什么了解？我的意思是，他们自己心怀感恩，因此能够树立表率吗？还是你发现很多父母根本不太理解？
We've done a few studies in this space. And so the first study we did, I would say parents saw themselves as fairly grateful. And I would say that was generally fairly truthful. And I would say that was generally fairly true. but we did see a lot of variation in how that played out, particularly how that translates to parenting of children. Sometimes it's hardest things for us to teach children are the things that we care about and we're good at because we just feel like they should get it. But in this case, we had a lot of emphasis on how those conversations were happening,
我们在这一领域做过一些研究。所以我们做的第一项研究，可以说父母认为自己相当感恩。而且我认为这总体上相当真实。而且我认为这总体上相当真实。但我们确实看到这在实际表现中存在很大差异，特别是这如何转化为对孩子的育儿方式。有时我们最难教给孩子的事情，恰恰是我们关心且擅长的事情，因为我们觉得他们应该自然而然地懂。但在这种情况下，我们非常强调这些对话是如何发生的，
and that's a different skill. It can be really hard to try to understand, like, why is your kid just not grateful in this moment when it seems so obvious they should be. And the intervention really starts with saying, well, wait a minute, what's going on with this seven-year-old right now and what are they focused on? So can we change that rather than push a narrative about being grateful in this moment? From the parents' perspective, can we start where that kid is, getting frustrated, and then move that conversation? Have you looked at all at differences based on socioeconomic status? I mean, I'm thinking of some people have a lot. and they're not very grateful for the things that they have, and some people have very little, and they totally get the idea of gratitude. What have you found?
而这是一项不同的技能。试图去理解可能会非常困难，比如，为什么你的孩子在这个时候就是不感恩，而明明很明显他们应该感恩。这项干预真正开始于说，嗯，等一下，这个七岁的孩子现在到底怎么了，他们关注的是什么？所以我们能不能改变这一点，而不是在这个时刻强行灌输关于感恩的叙述？从父母的角度来看，我们能否从那个正在感到沮丧的孩子所在的地方开始，然后推进对话？你有没有研究过基于社会经济地位的差异？我的意思是，我在想有些人拥有很多，但他们对拥有的东西并不怎么感恩，而有些人拥有很少，他们完全理解感恩的概念。你们发现了什么？
We started this work with people who had more resources because we were curious about how intentional they were being about gratitude in that context. And we've looked at a variety of groups at this point, and probably the research with adults has been a better job of answering this question, and there isn't necessarily a big correlation, between gratitude and SES or socioeconomic status. And so that's not something that we're seeing. But I think part of that's because a lot of the focus here is on interpersonal gratitude. We talk a lot about the gift behind the gift.
我们开始这项工作时，对象是拥有更多资源的人，因为我们很好奇他们在那种情况下对感恩有多大的意向。到目前为止，我们研究了各种各样的群体，可能对成年人的研究在这方面做得更好，而感恩与社会经济地位（SES）之间不一定存在巨大的相关性。所以这不是我们所看到的情况。但我认为部分原因是这里的许多重点都放在人际感恩上。我们经常谈论礼物背后的礼物。
So it's not that present that you got. It's that sweater that I got has butterflies on it. And my aunt remembered that butterflies are my favorite. And so the gift is really how I was thought about by my aunt's rather than the actual sweater itself. So we don't always need that physical object even for that to be there. But we don't see a lot of differences, and it may be just from what you're saying, there's a lot of different ways that might be playing out. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about how parents can respond productively in the moment when their child does something really ungrateful.
所以重要的不是你收到的那个礼物。而是那件毛衣上有蝴蝶图案。我的阿姨记得蝴蝶是我最喜欢的。所以这份礼物真正体现的是我的阿姨想到了我，而不是毛衣本身。因此，即使为了让感恩存在，我们也不一定总是需要那个实物。但我们没有看到太多的差异，这可能只是因为你所说的那样，这其中有很多不同的发挥作用的方式。我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将讨论当孩子做出非常不感恩的事情时，父母如何在当下做出富有成效的回应。
Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日优惠让你的夏天即刻开始。是时候点燃夏季烧烤了，Next Grills 四燃烧器燃气烤炉特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节尽情招待亲友，Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外用餐区只需 499 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，不适用于某些情况。详情请参见 Homedepot.com/pricematch。你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路在哪。
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app
我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订
and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. How should parents respond in the moment when a kid does something really ungrateful. For example, child gets a present from grandma that they don't really like and they throw it aside rather than say, thank you.
即可节省高达 20%，获得你期望的住宿体验。当你想要省钱，而不是惊吓时。你住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，静享精彩住宿。当孩子做出非常不感恩的事情时，父母在当时应该如何回应？例如，孩子从奶奶那里收到了一件他们其实并不喜欢的礼物，他们随手把它扔在一边，而不是说谢谢。
How should parents respond in those instances? For parents, there's usually many things happening in those instances, right? Grandma is their mom and their mom is looking at them to see how they're going to parent. So I think one of the things that we see is the more that parents get really distressed and they sort of internalize their kid's gratitude as a reflection of their parenting in the moment, then that kind of gets really difficult to separate. Parents sometimes make choices they're a little bit more punishing or a little bit more blaming or a little bit more harsh in the moment.
在这些情况下，父母应该如何回应？对于父母来说，在这些情况下通常会发生很多事情，对吧？奶奶是他们的妈妈，而他们的妈妈正看着他们，看他们将如何育儿。所以我认为我们看到的一点是，父母越是感到非常痛苦，并且他们在当下把孩子的感恩内化为对自己育儿方式的一种反映，那么这种事情就很难被分离开来。父母有时会做出在当时看来更具惩罚性、更多指责或更严厉的选择。
And those don't tend to foster gratitude over time. The other side of that is a lot of giving in in those moments. The classic example is what's happening in the checkout aisle. when a child is really wanting something is starting to throw a foot about that, it's really easy to give in and get out of the store, but then we see more of those moments coming. So what we kind of focus on is probably
而这些往往不利于随着时间的推移培养感恩。另一面是在那些时刻过多的妥协。经典的例子是结账通道里发生的事情，当孩子非常想要某个东西并开始为此大哭大闹时，妥协并离开商店是很容易的，但随后我们会看到更多这样的时刻。所以我们关注的焦点可能是
there's an in-the-moment response and then there's a later conversation response. And so we do think it's important that parents are telling kids the behavior that they think they should be doing and engaging in, but also a little bit about why. But that may be the moment or may not be the moment to have that conversation.
有一个当下的回应，然后有一个后来的对话回应。因此，我们确实认为，父母在这些时刻可以做的事情是多种因素的结合，其中还包括一些什么是不太有帮助的，但底线是管理好你自己的回应，这样你就可以成为那个冷静的父母，在当下给出你希望得到的指示，但随后再去剖析孩子在当下到底怎么了
So we think that it's a combination of things that parents can be doing in those moments. And there's some about what is less helpful, but the bottom line is managing your own response so that you can be sort of the calm parent to give the directive that you're hoping to get in the moment, but later unpack what's going on for the kid in the moment
以及为什么这件事在当时没有上升到让他们感恩的层面。也许这是一个不公平的问题，因为这又关乎年龄，但孩子们在什么点才会明白，即使奶奶送了你一件你不喜欢的礼物，你也必须说谢谢并假装你很喜欢它？嗯，这可能与感恩没有太大关系。这关乎我们对社会规范的顺从，对吧？以及我们的一种社会习俗。
and why that didn't rise to the service for them of gratitude in the moment. Maybe this is an unfair question because it's about age again, But at what point do kids understand that even if grandma gave you a gift you didn't like, that you have to say thank you and pretend that you did like it? Well, and that is probably not so much about gratitude. That's about sort of our social rules of conformity, right? And our kind of our social conventions.
它们看起来可能一样，但可能并非如此。不同的文化在这方面的做法大相径庭。我认为这是关于感恩的众多地方之一，在这些地方，鉴于我们被赋予了什么，我们对我们所说和所做之事的某些文化期望，确实是我们学会遵循的剧本。这可能不完全是感恩，但它可能会顺水推舟，帮助我们注意到值得感恩的事物。所以理想情况下，你知道，奶奶又送了我袜子，而我偏偏不是那种喜欢穿袜子的孩子。
And they can look the same, but they're probably not. And different cultures do this so differently. And I think this is one of the places of many places around gratitude where some of these cultural expectations for what we say and do given what we're being given are really scripts that we learn to follow. And that probably isn't exactly gratitude, but it may grease the rails to help us notice things to be grateful for. So ideally, you know, Grandma gave me socks again and I'm just not a socks kid. but I know that grandma remembered to get something for me and that she thought about me is the thing that I'm grateful for. And that's probably something that we can get on board with
但我知道奶奶记得给我买点东西，而且她想到了我，这是我感激的事情。这可能是一件我们更能接受的事情，
a little bit more than the socks. How can parents and other caregivers balance encouraging gratitude in their kids while acknowledging that the world can be frustrating, difficult, and unfair? I think the idea that gratitude is always good and appropriate in context is not true. I think when we talk about genuine gratitude, we really are talking about when we get things and we're saying, hey, I think I got this because somebody gave this to me in a way that it wasn't that I earned it from my effort. It was given to me at kindness. I don't owe something back. So gratitude has some cognitions around it, some attributions that we make about why we've got something that may not happen in circumstances.
而不是袜子本身。父母和其他照顾者如何在鼓励孩子感恩的同时，又承认世界可能是令人沮丧的、困难的和不公平的？我认为“感恩在任何背景下总是好且合适的”这种想法是不正确的。我认为当我们谈论真正的感恩时，我们实际上是在谈论当我们得到东西时，我们在说，嘿，我想我得到这个是因为有人以一种并非我通过努力挣来的方式把它给了我。它是出于善良给我的。我不欠别人什么。因此，感恩周围有一些认知，有一些关于为什么我们得到某样东西的归因，这些归因在某些情况下可能不会发生。
where gratitude doesn't turn out. And that's probably appropriate. So if somebody gives us something and we have the sense that we're going to owe them back for it, there's strings attached to this gift. That's probably something that's going to make us feel grateful. And that's probably okay because we need to think about that gift a little bit differently. You might feel a more indebted. I don't know that it's true that we want to say every time you've gotten something, you should feel grateful because that's really not how those gifts are all working. And as you're, as you're suggesting here, the world's a little more complicated than that. How did you get interested in studying gratitude? You mentioned that this really wasn't your
在这些情况下感恩并没有出现。这可能是适当的。所以如果有人给了我们一些东西，我们有一种感觉，我们要为此回报他们，这份礼物是有附加条件的。这可能会让我们感到感激。这大概也没关系，因为我们需要对这份礼物有稍微不同的思考。你可能会感到更多的负债感。我不知道我们是否应该说，每次你得到东西时，你都应该感到感激，因为这真的不是所有这些礼物运作的方式。正如你在这里所暗示的那样，世界比这要复杂得多。你是怎么对研究感恩产生兴趣的？你提到这真的不是你的
area and then all of a sudden bingo, you decided to work in it. Yeah, it was a backdoor for me. So I was doing a research study where we were doing an intervention with moms in recovery from addiction who had preschool-aged kids, so a little two to six-year-olds. And we were doing some traditional parent training, but a lot of focus on emotion and what kids could learn about emotion regulation in these early years when they're really ramping up emotion regulation skills. And in the course of doing this pilot work, we had one of the moms in the study who was just super grateful to the therapist working with her. And she would say it every time she came in. It was easy for her to engage in the sessions and in the homework. work, and we had another mom who had a very hard time with that. And we had the sense that
领域，然后突然之间，bingo，你决定从事这方面的研究了。是的，对我来说这是一条后门路径。当时我正在做一个研究项目，我们对处于戒毒康复期、有学龄前儿童（也就是两到六岁的小孩子）的妈妈们进行干预。我们做了一些传统的父母培训，但重点放在情绪上，以及孩子们在这些早期情绪调节技能迅速提升的时期，能学到关于情绪调节的什么知识。在这个试点工作的过程中，我们有一位研究中的妈妈对与她合作的治疗师非常感激。她每次来都会表达这一点。她很容易就能投入到课程和家庭作业中，
her trauma history got in the way because gratitude, there's an element of trust in there. There's an element of being able and willing to receive. And that was just very hard for her. And we were really interested in, well, you know, could we turn back the clock for these moms and help them have some gratitude that would help them find pro-social others in their life and develop a more positive network so that they have some. protection going forward. So we sat down and said, great, we've got a parenting program. Let's just see what's in the research literature about teaching children gratitude. And we'll just put that in our parenting program. And there were zero studies, nothing. So we really had to go back and start
而我们有另一位妈妈在这方面遇到了很大的困难。我们有一种感觉，她的创伤历史阻碍了她，因为感恩中包含着信任的成分。包含着能够并且愿意接受的成分。而这正是她非常难做到的。我们真的很感兴趣，嗯，你知道，我们能不能为这些妈妈们把时钟拨回过去，帮助她们产生一些感恩之情，这可以帮助她们在生活中找到具有亲社会倾向的人，并建立一个更积极的网络，以便她们未来有一些保护。所以我们坐下来讨论，太棒了，我们有一个育儿项目。让我们看看研究文献中关于教导儿童感恩的内容有什么。然后我们把它放进我们的育儿项目里。结果是零研究，什么都没有。所以我们真的不得不回头，从
with just thinking about what gratitude was in children, because there's a lot in the popular press, but the actual scientific literature was very thin. Given that we have such a me-fews, focused culture these days, are you finding it more difficult to help instill gratitude in children and even to work with their parents? I have found parents to be particularly interested in this. And a lot of our work has really focused on gratitude outfacing, but parent-child relationships where there's not a lot of gratitude coming back and forth is very difficult to negotiate. It's difficult for parents. And so I think they stay interested even just from, having a functional parent-child relationship and how gratitude might be playing out for their kids.
思考儿童身上的感恩是什么开始，因为大众媒体上有很多内容，但实际的科学文献却非常薄弱。鉴于如今我们拥有如此以自我为中心的文化，你是否发现帮助孩子树立感恩之心甚至与他们的父母合作变得更加困难了？我发现父母对此特别感兴趣。我们的很多工作实际上都集中在面向外部的感恩上，但是父母与孩子之间如果没有多少来来往往的感恩，谈判起来就会非常困难。这对父母来说很难。所以我想他们即使仅仅从维持一个功能良好的亲子关系以及感恩可能对孩子发挥什么作用的角度出发，也依然保持着兴趣。
That's not to say that it's not competing with all kinds of other things. It's confusing when you have a very achievement-oriented and competitive sort of orientation to be thinking about gratitude at the same time. They don't have to be opposites, but they can feel like opposites. And these are some of the other values that are out there. I think that any time we're talking about, about values with our children and our families, any one value feels pretty easy to get on board with. It's the constellation of them. And when they come into conflict, that's really the hard part for us to figure out. So what are you working on now? What are the big questions that remain to be answered? There are a number of questions about gratitude that we think are important.
这并不是说它没有与其他各种事情竞争。当你有一种高度追求成就和竞争的倾向时，同时去思考感恩就会让人感到困惑。它们不一定是相对的，但它们可能会让人感觉像是相对的。这些是现存的其他一些价值观。我认为，每当我们在谈论我们与孩子和家庭的价值观时，任何单一的价值观都感觉很容易接受。难的是它们的组合。当它们发生冲突时，这才是我们真正难以弄清楚的部分。那么你现在在做什么？还有哪些重大问题亟待解答？关于感恩，有许多我们认为很重要的问题。
One of them really has to do with thinking about how it changes across context and how it changes across culture, big culture and little culture and families in terms of how we think about that we think is important. But the cultural context is taking me back to where I started. So right now we're trying to look at the way that moms in recovery are fostering gratitude and generosity and love in their children and how we think about that in the context of trauma and adversity and how those come together. So we're doing some of that work. At the same time, we're doing a little bit of work using virtual reality to see if we can give people experiences of the world in a different way that help them experience things like self-compassion and gratitude.
其中之一实际上与思考它如何在不同语境下改变、如何在不同文化下改变（宏观文化、微观文化以及家庭在如何看待这一点上）有关，我们认为这很重要。但文化背景把我带回了我开始的地方。所以现在我们正试图研究处于戒毒康复期的妈妈们是如何在孩子身上培养感恩、慷慨和爱的，以及我们在创伤和逆境的背景下如何看待这一点以及这些因素是如何融合在一起的。所以我们正在做一些这样的工作。与此同时，我们也在做一些工作，利用虚拟现实来看看我们是否能以一种不同的方式为人们提供世界的体验，帮助他们体验诸如自我同情和感恩之类的事物。
So we're continuing to try to find ways to get the work out to where people are most interested in engaging with it. Well, Dr. Hussling, I want to thank you for joining me today. I thank you. I think this has been useful for our listeners, and I appreciate your taking the time. Well, it's been a wonderful conversation. Thank you so much, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
因此，我们一直在努力寻找方法，将这项工作带到人们最感兴趣参与的地方。那么，胡松博士，我要感谢你今天能来。谢谢你。我认为这对我们的听众很有用，我很感激你抽出时间。嗯，这是一次非常棒的对话。非常感谢你，金。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学聊天室》以前的单集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请留下评价。如果你对未来的单集有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. You can't reason with the sun. Trust us. We've tried. This summer, it's time to put that angry ball of fire on mute. Columbia's Omnishade Technologies engineered to protect you from the sun's harsh rays that can burn and damage your skin. The sun is relentless, but so is our gear.
《心理学聊天室》由李·韦内曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。你无法与太阳讲道理。相信我们。我们试过了。今年夏天，是时候将那个愤怒的火球按静音键了。哥伦比亚（Columbia）的 Omnishade 科技旨在保护你免受太阳刺眼光芒的伤害，这些光芒会灼伤和损伤你的皮肤。太阳是无情的，但我们的装备也是如此。
Level up your summer at Columbia.com to spend more time outside and less time slathering on allotion you're welcome columbia engineered for whatever There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 Columbia.com 上升级你的夏天，花更多时间在户外，少花时间涂抹乳液，不客气。Columbia 专为各种户外活动而设计。这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。